uh how much money is in your guys'
savings account right now a little bit
more than um half a million cool in
fifth we have
Mercedes this way what anyone else I
think I'm just too rich for these guys y
I'm
sorry how's everyone doing good I know
you guys just went through this but how
does it feel being on the other side I
hope they're not salty yeah oh this is
the one where they put that dude in last
cuz he cried and he was a little
emotional yeah yeah you trying to cry
now no I lost my best friend this year
so it's still have been he thing for me
so sorry made me think about it I'm so
sorry oh my
god um I really appreciated his honesty
and vulnerability
1 hour later fifth we have West told you
at yeah yeah if you do that to me I'm
salty cuz I literally cried salt tears
so you go you go you go taste it yeah
you have something to say about my tears
that went hor yeah if that's me I'm
salty
first I mean it's just the tattoos and
the freckles like I'm a big tattoo guy
so what are you going to be looking for
physically in someone who's not short
cuz I don't know it's kind of weird if
you're tall and you like someone who's
kind of short it's kind of weird it's
not oh come give me a hug go it's not
that that bad no it's amazing I don't
even know what people are tripping about
yeah all my short Queens out there love
y'all short Queens are better than tall
Queens I don't discriminate yeah as a
man who has like trouble with his
masculinity a shorter woman helps me out
I can understand yeah yeah I don't give
a because like sometimes it's like
tall women be like pick me up that a me
I had a 61 girl tell me to pick her up I
was like word oh yeah yeah let's keep
moving past that fantasy and come back
to real my next not my neck snap uh your
what if my neck snap
uhhuh if your next snap what my neck
snap if I die I
die okay or what oh Oh you mean pick
them up with your arms my bad I said it
to you flipflop she should move up why
do you think I think she just she has
like she has like a really nice body it
looks like realiz she she
likes good body yeah I'm just GL didn't
say personality I'm like don't make me
Rob she looks like drama though just the
way she did her makeup she looks like
she's going to ruin your life MH where
do you think the men will place you um
honestly I think I will be somewhere
around a little bit above mid
because because this is how I would rank
my because I look better in these
and then YouTube and then you
switch YouTu flipflop there we go I'm
not mad at this where do you think you
might wind up in
line probably she probably going to say
like last or before last cuz that's how
she thinks these men would see her but
not how she sees herself or how the men
she normally likes would see her MH all
right let me see if I know my black
women on the lower half not because I
don't think I'm beautiful I just think
that there is a specific standard of
beauty right now now and
I why you got to be so violent all the
time hey why do you think we make this
YouTube money so I could afford to throw
these
FES to throw these clothes what the
is wrong with you I'm feeling myself I
could see that but godamn can you chill
Hey sisters don't ever say I don't know
y'all don't ever think I don't see y'all
don't pay attention to y'all don't know
my newb sister you didn't do nothing
special my Queens is tether to the black
do nothing special calm down Zulu knows
oh my God yeah yeah yeah yeah you've
left wakanda so you would have know what
that vibranium connection like is
stronger than any other metal on this
planet you did all that to just say that
why did you just say that you could have
just be like hey say now and then we
would have went on no you threw your
phone youing Chuck the
door over there you threw some clothes
across the room you did
that whole thing just to go really did
do you think that the revolution would
be
simple are you done federal agent oh
it's me that is federal
a every time I'm trying to bring on
people together we always have to have
one don't ever forget it was a brother
who killed Malcolm has to move down a
little
[Music]
bit I think moves down to three yeah
three all right we can do
that I'm good with this lineup this yeah
yeah yeah what what was going through
your mind when you had your headphones
on and you were getting
judged um I honestly was in another
planet I was just like vibing by myself
I was not staring at them and I was kind
of just not really caring because I
really don't care what they
think do you guys do you guys drive yeah
you drive yes yes cool I hate this guy
this guy is weird he's always he's been
like that since the last video he's one
of those dudes like my awkwardness is my
personality and I just say random
in it like oh that's funny shut up are
you guys wearing socks oh yeah cool
that's that's great I'm so
awkward oh I I like underwear too I wear
them every
day what is your one red flag and one
beige flag it's I don't think it's a red
flag but guys usually do I do musical
theater what no that's red flag red flag
red flag you know me and theater kids
don't trust none of these mother they
act for a living do not trust anybody
who does theater I know we got fans who
trust theaters don't come to our shows
don't come say hi to me cuz I don't want
to see you mother did you throw your
phone again y it's a iPhone we make
money what's the
problem I came and I will okay hi um I'm
Victoria and my red flag okay um I think
it's my expectation I expect a lot from
everyone um I don't know if I can meet
my own standard sometimes you're Asian
that's what I got to say sorry hard to
impress me um a beige flag is I don't
like to party I don't like to party um I
don't like people I think a red flag for
me some people are very bothered because
I say bagle no way are you Canadian yes
I am yeah and she's from the and she
from the Prairies she from like
Edmonton uh Winnipeg what he say bagel
bagle bagel bagle it's really more like
bagle yeah like a bag everybody else
just says yo can I get a bagel yes I
know flag people either like or really
dislike that I have tattoos makes sense
actually that makes sense that makes
sense that's really is red flag I would
say that um I have a hard time to
communicate about feelings sometimes so
that's definitely a red flag I think
that's just Eastern European she's
European yes it's okay it's not your
fault the Cold War happened all the men
went off the war died and the ones who
came back were alcoholics hard to
express yourself when you're partner is
a dead beat or an alcoholic a lot of
Eastern European men are watching right
now it's okay you're one of the few good
ones yeah I'm not crazy about white
women but if his her name is old go then
she could have my body Jesus Christ yeah
she could like burn a cigarette on my
chest and say shut up you I
don't let's move on shut up
you will make good
husband you'll make the best husband and
I'll never let anyone do it but if your
name's Olga holl at your boy I don't
care if I'm in a relationship holler at
you boy we're not going to sleep
together but she gets a burn a cigarette
on my CH God damn what's wrong with that
is that cheating what the wait wait wait
we think about it is that cheating yes
it is is it though yes it is how is it
cheating what everybody get in the
comment is that cheating let's say
you're in a relationship okay you get an
olga there's no penetration no kissing
she just walks in the room she walks in
she walks in she says shut hold on hold
on hold on hold on hold on hold on got
you this want to get like
you want to take my cigar just to burn
it on my pause that's
crazy what happened last night I just
met a girl you what yeah oh my god did
you sleep together no she just
uh burn a cigarette on my
chest it's cheating
I'm a loyal man I
promise yeah you are I was going to say
the same thing that I'm not really a
party person um I might look like it but
I'm I like to stay at home I guess my
red flag would be I think I have a
strong personality and I'm like not
afraid to say how I feel maybe that's a
beige is that a beige that can be a
beige that be a
beige a red flag is I like to go out I
like to go outside the base flag
kind kind falls in the beige FL category
a red flag I talk a lot I like to talk I
talk a lot still in the beige
category like can we go out all this
is beige and I like it come on give some
real this is beige and I like it what's
your red flag my red flag what's my red
flag I didn't have to think about that
in a long time okay so they there what
so there so that what's my Bas FL what's
my red flag since you know go ahead
what's your red flag yeah go ahead uh
you are really bad at communicating
YouTube YouTube YouTube you be saying
something like you be
like I like write you a paragraph you be
like okay cuz it's
so you see the way SM you know that's
fine that's fine but I'm just saying
that's a red flag in a dating context
you you you might Mur some women that's
one thing I could say I sound angry all
the time or unb bothered and hm
sometimes they're right yeah my my my
red flag impatient 100% easy you don't
have to make those eyes I said it myself
I didn't see I didn't see my guy I
see show them eyes I don't know say
it again say it again I'm impatient
yeah didn't say nothing huh say okay
okay I didn't don't play me don't play
me why you being impatient right
now dies all right
cool I can admit my own fault
I I admited my faults too what I can't
be I can't agree no you don't have to
agree so loudly I didn't say your
eyes were really loud though my God they
might not have been watching their
screen but they went yo preach why you
giving them that look girls cleaning
like yo preach staring at him real hard
anyways I'm calling out all you people
who are playing our videos without
watching okay all you people who are
doing something else doing your homework
doing other look at the camera
right
now don't say nothing don't say nothing
don't say nothing if they didn't look at
the camera they don't know so they won't
have to come and Rewind that they
all about to rewind they all have to
rewind you know think I don't know how
you watch our videos you know
think I don't
know all right don't say nothing sh
don't say don't tell me what we did
don't tell me what we did they have to
see the video so they have to be at the
screen okay let's keep going let's keep
going I feel bad cuz a lot of people who
watch us regularly like they watch the
video they're like yo why does that do
weird yeah well okay anyways this
they going to be like yo 2024 is wow yes
it is uh how much money is in your guys'
savings account right
now heyo what the no comment no comment
I like to shop I do so if that tells you
anything going to say a little bit more
than um half a million
cool I want to know whose life she
ruined to get that money I want to know
whose life she ruined to get that money
what's your only fans what's your only
fans she strikes me as a type of person
who's d need some rich guys and taking
advantage of
it not
that but I don't know I don't really
want to share I love it yeah I'm good
I'm I'm good
yeah would our attractiveness be defined
by money no no not at all it's just like
a kind of gacha question like do you
save for the future yeah just
like just wondering what a dumb question
ask like I don't know why that girl said
have a million cuz that's just a red
flag in a lot of weird ways is it is it
why is it we flag cuz she's relatively
young so you'd be questioning like how
did you get that money unless you have a
really good explanation it's a red flag
and then also if you've really earned
that money properly you're generally not
apt to just volunteer that information
because it invites trouble into your
life what's her name Mercedes Mercedes
what SM SM Smith NOA what's the last
name maybe she's a year or something we
don't know maybe your family got money
like
that maybe I'm wrong my bad yeah
Mercedes can you like tell us what you
do to got like such a big Bank uh I work
in social media
oh what your only fan
girl she's the air to what the only fans
yeah she's that social media I don't
believe that that's normally what people
say when they're tricking or when
they're tricking oh where they go to
Dubai tricking let me Che this girl
socials 1.6 million yeah she
tricking she's an
actress she's an actress she did what
she did a bunch of one-off episodes as
like like very small roles you don't
save half a million from that no that's
not where she got her money okay top 0
1% of all creators okay yeah you were
right what food do you hate like what
what you like God I
can't pickles sea all Seafood even like
sushi
I know I thought they going to ask more
like deeper questions just to get to
know me as a person it was just like dry
like do you feel like you guys asked
enough questions to get to know the
women God no not at all you know what
though they keep letting this
weirdo ask the question so they deserve
whatever they get these are dumb
questions but they let the dumb person
ask the dumb question so whatever it is
you really don't like that guy what food
do
you how much do you have in your savings
C what's your social insurance number do
you have a mom and a dad or is it like a
mom and a
mom I'm listen I give the women Flack
when they act goofy that goofy super
goofy that guyy goofy what's the
craziest thing you've done to an ex like
what's the worst thing you did to an ex
try to him
again that's as far as it goes for me
cuz I knew I was no good for that but I
she was great for
otherwise I'm on good terms in my exes
we just you know what do you think is
the strangest thing that turns you
on bad I think when when men are just
backing up with the car and they kind of
put the head over
them a lot of girls like that A lot
of girls like that this one okay so
when you're driving you're in the you're
in the you're you're driving okay and
then you're about to power part okay and
the girl sitting right next to you and
then you part and if you put your hand
right behind her her back to back it up
and you do it one time they love that
really
mhm
yep they back when you back it up it's
the hand behind yeah the hand behind is
like you taking care of the car and the
whole situation so yeah they like that
I've heard girls say that a lot yeah
normally me cuz I don't drive so on my
bicycle and I see a girl and I stop in
front of her and then I unbuckle my
helmet I'm like Safety First it normally
gets super wet yeah absolutely yeah
definitely I'm like would you like a
ride there's some rental bikes over
there let's just ride together all right
safety's sexy sure yeah lets them know
I'm tested and everything yeah really
kind men like it's just like just people
who are just kind for no reason like
there was no reason for you to do this
thing for this person you don't know cuz
I know like some people are like bad
boys are like the I like people who are
very very
[Music]
sweet not this guy not Mr I cried on
camera getting H turned on by kindness
oh my
[Music]
God uh put her there because I feel we
have a lot of like things in common she
kind of scared me I'm not going to lie I
feel like she would like beat me up and
then uh it was just didn't have really
much in common uh I feel like if we were
to hang out we would just kind of sit
there in silence um and then we would
have opposite things be funny to each
other so that would be like fun to be
[Music]
around I just need a break just give me
a second before I get through
this of like trying to get someone who
doesn't think you're funny to laugh she
was pretty but kind of not my type and
um not really my type at all number one
cuz uh physically and I think now
getting to know them this would
definitely be someone I would go for
damn they got the Asian girl fif the
tall one mhm and I'm not mad cuz her
personality was drier than
biscuits mhm she was she was
dry and the only bigger red flag that
dry ass personality is 500k in the
savings account with no
explanation we we know the explanation
yeah yeah but just own it then she don't
have to I don't like it when people do X
work and they want to be ambiguous she
don't have to like why you using Code
language uh I do social I don't it's I
got a social media account and I ain't
doing 500k what you doing just say it's
fine I kep I respect the X workk when
it's just in public open no I don't I
know I don't care about that they don't
she don't know those dudes she don't owe
them do ow them anything I understand
the IG instance like some people that
you're going to be like just man
whatever do this this do that sometimes
you choose your battle and you don't
have to I agree okay so
but why mention the 500k cuz that was
the question that was asked okay and
they also ask what you do and you
decided to not be ambiguous social
social media okay so you want to flaun
all this stuff about watches or whatever
it is but then people ask your money you
be like I run a business that's corny
you run a business I get it I'm sorry I
get I think it's corny if you want to
talk about how much money you got but
then you want to be ambiguous about what
you do you look Shady that's a red flag
just don't mention the money if you
don't want those questions but don't say
something coded like social just say
what you do cuz you sound like a scammer
now sure so that's you have to hold that
L cuz I couldn't imagine going on a date
with a girl I'm flashing all this stuff
I'm talking about how much money I make
then she asking like what do you do for
work and then I'm being ambig I get you
doesn't that maybe I'm off though is
that not a rich with with the ex worker
and how it is viewed I understand how
people are are be like just a little
protective about that you you can ask
about the money and that's I I answer
what you do social media she was not
lying yes she was being vague but I
think she was lying so if you if you're
smart enough you put two and two
together you see this and that and the
third in fifth we have
Mercedes this way what what what in
fourth Victoria third we have zenab in
second Jordan and in first Charlie with
19 points slay do you girls have any
thoughts about the final order of this
line I mean I'm kind of shocked I did
not think they were vibing with me at
all anyone else I think I'm just too
rich for these guys yo I'm sorry true El
she she hurt she hurt but I don't feel
bad for you sister because you made your
bed now you got a lie in it you should
have just been honest my point my point
was I understand why she did it your
point was I understand why you're not
you're going to Old the L I don't
understand why you're it's not going to
be attractive and why so I understand
why she did it you too understand why
she did it absolutely right I get it but
your point was more on the it look shady
and I was like yeah I understand why you
got into that place so so yeah we agree
I'm not asking ex-workers to run around
be like this yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so we be don't
be don't don't be don't be mad when that
happened you know what we're all
different I can't be for everyone and
that's that's
okay
for the men's final order I was shocked
what were you shocked by I was like
although we all belong in number one I
feel like they don't really have taste
I'm not putting any girl oh she butt
hurt y yo can we just rewind yo we got
to rewind do you remember what she said
at the beginning what did she say at the
beginning what did you say she went oh I
need to we need a rewind I honestly was
in another planet I was just like vibing
by myself I was not staring at them and
I was kind of just not really caring
because I really don't care what they
think these guys have no taste what's
wrong with them I was shocked what
happened it do sound like you don't
care hey yo you know think I don't
remember I pay attention yeah the L's
like oh my God I you so you remember
little things no it's cuz I can use it
against you
I'm toxic it just look kind of
wholesome but
[Music]
it's yeah I remember oh I remember yeah
try to with me I remember what you
say I'll use it against you o I use it
against you o but only when you deserve
it n girl you can't tell me oh you know
what I eat anything and then all of a
sudden we go out to dinner and you
getting picky about everything well I
remember what you said on October 3rd
that's funny I'll pull up a receipt too
I'll be saving every conversation my
days I be recording phone calls Oh my
days I'm not putting any girls girls
down but I I definitely think it
reflected um how much they could handle
um a really bad
[Music]
I cannot believe what I am hearing
this is I what happened my favorite
Jubilee video of the last two years I
think men get inse secure when I talk
about my finances and they see that I'm
a little bit further than they are so
I'm not taking any offense here I'm not
upset about it I was kind of expecting
that that's what happened to me like
personally as a personal
experience no actually let me not
discoun experience there are definitely
some people are going to be insecure by
the fact that you make such a
substantial amount of money mhm okay um
but there's also another subset of
people who wouldn't have an issue with
it if you weren't being so overt about
it or if you weren't being so awkward
about it you know like there's plenty of
people who have the only fans who have
all their set up and they're able
to date a lot of people but they have to
meet people who are open but you also
have to be open and that's not how you
approached it um so I think you coming
in last you seemed a little bit shady
and also a lot of your answers were kind
of bit off the thing that happened is
that she like in her case she's damn if
she does damn if she doesn't right
because a lot of people are going to
have some um they're going to have some
stigma with doing what she does so if
she overtly say what she does boom
stigma but then if she say about it and
don't say it and just disclose it would
have been better it would have been
better if she would didn't she didn't
disclose the money and then disclose
what she does cuz go well if she didn't
disclose the money the what she does
there would have been a follow-up
question you understand what I'm saying
so yeah that's pretty much it I was I'm
planing to agree well not necessarily
this is what I would say for for me and
my perspective is it's damned if she
does and more damned if she doesn't and
the reason being is if you're dating
they need to know who you are right you
have to tell you're going to okay yes
you're going to lose a lot of people
because you tell them you do all fans
you're going to lose everyone because
you don't tell them
right right you can't leave a double
life in so I agree with you it's not an
easy choice but you've chosen that
lifestyle so you have to at least own it
and if you're not willing to own it then
don't expect to fall in love or don't
expect to date seriously or to taken
serious I couldn't be taken seriously if
I my j or I did not because I'm doing
anything weird but because I'm not being
confront it's weird it's worse if you
don't do anything wrong yeah and you're
hiding it what else for example if a
girl tells me she's unemployed okay if
the girl's hiding that she's unemployed
now I think she's really weird because
she's not only being deceptive about it
but she's offis scating from something
that normally people always tell each
other in relationships what are you even
doing here M you know so that's the main
thing but look I don't care if you're a
worker find love I hope find it there's
plenty of people who accept it there's
nothing wrong with that and I'm not
judgmental relationships like that no
not at all but don't lie I'm going enjoy
this cigar that was ending was the flip
flop the one of my favorite videos the
pancake yes sir the flip of the WR yo
listen uh the noodle toss amazing it was
amazing